house noting that multiple records can
be held against the same individual
so the number of individuals affected by
this incident
is likely to be lower operational
partners are still able to access the
police national computer which holds as
i say
over 13 million records mr speaker
clearly this situation
is very serious and i understand
colleagues across the house
will have concerns which of course i
share
mr speaker by your leave i want to set
out for the house the steps we've taken
to deal with this complex incident
on the evening of the 10th of january
the same day the home office became
aware of the incident
engineers put a stop on the automated
process to ensure no further deletions
took place
all similar automated processes have
also been suspended
early last week home office civil
servants and engineers worked quickly to
alert the police and other operational
colleagues
and established a bronze silver and gold
command to manage the incident and
coordinate a rapid response
the gold command provided rapid guidance
for police forces and other partners to
ensure they were kept abreast of the
situation
second homo office officials and
engineers working closely
with the national police chiefs council
police forces and other partners
immediately initiated rapid work through
the gold command
to assess the full scale and impact of
the incident
this included undertaking a robust and
detailed assessment and verification of
all affected records
followed by developing and implementing
a plan to recover as much of the data
and records as
possible and develop plans to mitigate
the impacts of any
lost data this is being done mr speaker
in four phases
phase one involves writing and testing a
code
to bring back accurate lists of what has
been deleted as a result of the incident
phase two will involve running that code
and then doing detailed analysis on the
return
to fully analyze the records which have
been lost and establish the full impact
phase three will be to begin the
recovery of the data from the police
national computer
and other linked systems and phase four
will involve work to ensure we are
deleting any data that should have been
deleted
as usual when this incident first began
phase one of this process has taken
place over the weekend and i am assured
it has gone well
the second phase is now underway and i
will hopefully have an update in the
next few days
while any loss of data is unacceptable i
can say that other tried and tested law
enforcement systems are in place
which contain linked data and reports to
support policing partners in their
day-to-day efforts to keep us safe
for example the police national database
or other local force systems
the police are able to use these systems
to do simultaneous checks
mr speaker i would urge patients while
we continue our rapid internal
investigation
and begin the recovery i hope the house
will appreciate that the task in front
of us
is a complex one public safety is the
top priority of everyone working at the
home office mr speaker
and i have full faith that home office
engineers and our partners in the
national police council and the police
force across the country
who we are working with are doing all
they can to restore this data
while this is rightly our immediate
priority clearly the home secretary and
i have commissioned an internal review
as to the circumstances which led to
this incident
so lessons can be learned i will update
this house regularly on process and i
commend this state into the house